[Music]  all the best christmas movies always  take place in quaint little towns full  of mom and pop shops and lots of holiday  cheer  merry christmas oh cindy merry christmas  christmas greetings one and all righty  you're here  honey do you know where the reservation  book is hold your horses i've got it  right here  these christmas movies are about you  know love yeah what's a good love story  without some twists and turns  [Music]  is there something i can do for you i  want to answer that in so many ways  we are running out of time you can't  just give up we're going to need some  help down here  maybe even a christmas miracle  [Music]  mary  freaking  christmas  you